gabriella talent le président de la
république a invité jean castex à boire
un petit verre en terrasse
bah moi aussi j'ai envie de vous inviter
à bon ben on envie qu'on ait tous
s'intéressent qu'à brown et moi on va
partir
[Applaudissements]
sung tout fait travailler des coûts ce
soir c'est pour moi prenez un petit
verre en terrasse et pour moi voir
compte allez y mollo un merci et en plus
on a on a de la chance il n'a pas fait
beau toute la journée
hélas alors à une accalmie et là ça va
mieux là ça va mieux merci merci merci
merci merci merci merci merci
alors alors enfin on va on va on va par
là c'est énorme cette ses comptables
bah je sais pas réservé mais on va voir
ce qu'on peut faire en tout cas je suis
très heureux ce soir de pouvoir partager
avec vous c'est vrai ce moment c'est un
moment on se serait dit ça ya dix ans
que quand on va les prendre un verre en
terrasse ce sera un événement
eh ben c'est vrai que c'est un événement
aujourd'hui pour tous ceux qui ont la
chance de retravailler pour tous ceux
qui ont la chance de reprendre espoir
j'ai vu des restaurateurs aujourd'hui
j'ai vu plein de gens ce midi plein de
sens disait on a tellement envie
travaillé on a tellement envie de
aujourd'hui voilà donc faire encore plus
et c'est incroyable de faire ça fait
déjà les gens vivent de leur travail
parce que c'est leur pression pas de
survivre avec des aides comme ça et les
gens vont le voyez même les gens qui
arrivent à s'en sortir avec les aides
disait j'ai envie de travailler et c'est
vrai que c'était s'est s'inquiété qui
était fou j'espère que ça va perdurer
crois pas retourner encore dans magna
fait par étapes
justement de manière prudente est ce
parce que le pierre ça serait d'aller
trop vite et devoir refermer
c'est exactement c'est ça donc là je
dirais que je sais qu'il ya des
restaurateurs qui ont pris beaucoup
beaucoup de mesures tu te fais beaucoup
d'efforts qui ont de sécurité ça aussi
c'est important
bien sûr il faut qu'il faut que le
protocole sanitaire il faut respecter
parce que c'est ça la condition qui nous
permet de rouvrir très bien alors je
vois qu'il ya du monde en tout cas alors
voilà il ya du monde pour soir
bonsoir bonsoir alors c'est vrai que
c'est énorme
il ya alors installez-vous bonsoir ça va
ça va bonsoir bonsoir alors est-ce qu'on
peut alors quadrillé latins ont tous
relevé le masque monter un salon alors
la règle c'est qu'on garde le match
jusqu'à ce qu'on soit la boisson
la premier plan à bercy on dit je savais
pas mais après il faut le remettre pour
payer une fois qu'on a consommé et vous
avez vu le monde qui en terrasse ou pas
fait plaisir c'est incroyable a
vachement bon soir bon je sais que les
jeunes et ça a été très dur et du roure
eux le fait prise ça l'est toujours et
donc les bras mais tout le monde a suivi
en fait sur le tube ou la voilà on est
en tout cas je suis très content d'être
avec vous
gabriel il ya plein de gens qui se pose
la question est-ce que vous pensez que
l'épidémie avec le vaccin avec tout ce
qui est mis en place
est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut pas
s'auto pas voilà peut pas dire on va
voir si on voit ce qui se passe dans les
autres pays est ce que pensaient qu'elle
en train de disparaître
ou est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
retourner dans un corps dans un
confinement dans un
c'est ça la crainte de voir que peuvent
le dire alors bah ça va merci les
gabriel cyr il ajouté vous passerez les
battre et jean baptiste
moi je vais prendre moi je te fondre
je prends le moins petit à petit diabolo
presse
coca zéro non mais c'est ça c'est ça la
question qu'on se pose c'est vrai que
c'est ça nous fait chier on est
tellement heureux de sortir que on se
dit on espère qu'on va pas on va pas
externe et moi c'est moi ça fait ça va
faire un an que je parte parole du
gouvernement
et si un truc que j'ai appris ça jamais
rien exclure par principe je peux pas
voilà j'ai pas là je peux pas dire que
tu auras pas un moment une nouvelle
personne à la rue dans le monde deux
chaudières sont les deux choses c'est
que quand on fait tout pour l'empêcher
pour ça qu'on fait des choses par étapes
on garde un protocole sanitaire etc et 2
il ya un an on avait que des boucliers
pour se battre le gyrus c'est à dire le
masque et les gestes barrière rapide on
a une arme c'est le vaccin s'est servi
au vaccin ça peut nous permettre
d'espérer quand même de sortir
durablement de l'épidémie en tout cas on
voit dans les pays qui ont fait ce
qu'ils ont vacciné très massivement déjà
voilà ils jouent ils ont l'air quand
même d'en être sorti assez durablement
donc il faut espérer que ça va du masque
on en parlait tout à l'heure on va
pouvoir l'on va l'abandonner comme
totalement j'espère à l'été et espère à
l'extérieur avec ça les gens qui lisent
ya des des maires de communes qui disent
qu'ils vont peut-être prend des arrêtés
pour leurs l'enlever voilà qui voit ses
qualités ou dans ce serait prendre un
risque de se précipiter de dire tout de
suite on arrête tout de suite toutes les
mesures barrières
ce serait prendre le risque ça reparte
on doit à nouveau prendre des mesures de
confinement de fermeture de resto de
commerce etc
vaut mieux faire ça progressivement de
manière prudente que ça soit durable
donc voilà l'idée qu'on pourra plus d'un
an maintenant que on avait l'apparition
de cette épidémie
c'est quoi votre plus mauvais souvenir
je pense quand même que c'est un
deuxième continent parce que le premier
confinement il ya le choc c'est puis bon
ça n'a vécu quelque chose
d'extraordinaire à ce moment là c'était
quelque chose d'inédit y avait pas la
lassitude qu'on avait six mois plus tard
au moment du deuxième film ans quand je
me suis retrouvé en conseil de défense
avec les présidents de la république le
premier ministre a dû se rendre à
l'évidence on n'avait pas d'autre choix
que de continuer là j'avoue que c'est
dur c'est dur parce que derrière c'est
des gens qu'on empêche de travailler
c'est des gens pensent les jeunes à des
étudiants m'empêche de voir leurs amis
d'aller en cours ils sont derrière
qu'est ce que vous dites aux
restaurateurs qui disent qu'on aurait pu
rouvrir plutôt les terrasses
un peu plus tôt voilà et qu'on aurait pu
reprendre le travail un peu plus tôt qu
est ce que vous leur dites
il ya quelques semaines encore nous deux
semaines quand j'allais sur les plateaux
télé on me disait qu'on allait trop vite
et qu'on rouvre est il ya des
scientifiques disaient vous allez
beaucoup trop libre ouvrir le 19 c'est
beaucoup trop tôt etc
on fait au mieux fait au mieux et pour
moi ce que je peux dire c'est que à
chaque fois
on considère qu'on peut alléger une
restriction qu'on peut rouvrir quelque
chose et c'est sûr de le faire on le
fait on n'attend pas par plaisir
vincee étudier des vidéos on se
retrouver avec des nouvelles vagues
l'important ça a été aussi d'accompagner
les restaurateurs les commerçants qui
étaient fermiers
tous et moins financièrement pour qu'il
tienne c'est aujourd'hui peuvent rouvrir
c'est parce qu'ils ont tenu jusqu'à
maintenant sans travailler parce qu'on
les a choisis bien sûr après elle a
beaucoup qui pouvait les aides elles ont
été importantes et c'est vrai qu'on est
le seul pays je pense avoir créé autant
dead et ce à tout le monde tout le monde
est d'accord là dessus
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il ya des
restaurateurs qui se dit aussi que les
aides ça n'a pas été suffisant pour eux
parce que c'est ils ont été fermés
énormément de temps et qu'aujourd'hui il
y en a beaucoup qui disent voilà c'est
notre dernière chance on aurait aimé
c'est notre dernière chance et je le
rajoute ont très bien saisi
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on maintient les
aides moi je connais des restaurateurs
vous
ok on peut rouvrir avec la moitié de
votre terrasse
voilà comment on fait alors que on a un
seuil de rentabilité et c'est pour ça
qu'on met qui restera tant ils vont
recevoir les mêmes aides qu'ils avaient
un abri pour qu'ils étaient fermés les
airs un merci merci beaucoup merci à
tous ce qu'ils font là en terme de
consommer et sait c'est que l'on sait
que du bénef pour ce mois d'août c'est
ça ouais encore qu'à 0 c'est pour faire
ça et on va continuer à les aider c'est
à dire que même en juin 11 juillet en
août
on va continuer à leur verser des aides
pour compenser le fait que
non on parle del mastro pour le vase
c'est quoi merci beaucoup monsieur vous
êtes content vous êtes contents de vous
êtes content d'avoir ouvert ou pas c'est
aussi l'âge et rassurez vous
reconnaissez gabriel atta le porte
parole du gouvernement
il a écouté avec une passion ouais ces
derniers dans c'est quoi certes c'est un
moment de bonheur bon alors pour nous
c'est non seulement à votre bonheur et
je vais vous expliquer mieux avec nos
principes nos bistrots nos cafés
c'est un petit peu parlement du peuple
c'est vrai j'ai regardé autour de moi là
les gens se parlent les gens comme
l'indiquent ça nous fait plaisir qu'on a
presque quel bonheur quel bonheur de
voir les gens je le vois ils ont le
sourire ils sont heureux d'être là ils
sont heureux
son printemps son très attendu vingt
minutes trente mille juste pourquoi
c'est juste d'être assis à table et
respect du soleil aujourd'hui on
al'impression de guerre de cette
légèreté avec des contrats visés par une
matière financière des contraintes
bien sûr on n'est pas dans notre hub et
aux piétons attention que vous avez pris
beaucoup de mesures vous avez fait des
désinvestissements aussi pour remettre
tous en question bien sûr est
antinomique pour un restaurateur excusez
moi de dire ne soyez pas si sympa c'est
vrai vous écouter eloignez-vous bien sûr
c'est des choses qui sont très
difficiles à faire mon effet avec
plaisir si c'est pour sortir de cette
crise
aujourd'hui mais de recommencer
progressivement mais nous avons aussi
c'est que les restaurateurs avant même
le co lead c'est déjà une profession qui
a décrit tout volé en termes d'hygiène
savoir l'éditeur
donc ça vient en plus c'est vrai je dois
je sais vous vous avez du boulot et je
comprends je remercie et je vais plus
loin
enfin merci beaucoup merci en tout cas
remercier mon chéri alors kerviel s'il y
avait un meilleur souvenir c'est quoi
pour moi c'est celui-là c'est
aujourd'hui un jour de revoir ça c'est
parce que y a pas deux mais il n'y a pas
de y'a pas de bons souvenirs dans celle
que je pense que je vis mon meilleur
souvenir de porte parole eh ben ça me
fait plaisir que vit avec moi
franchement c'est pour nous je vais
quand même s'il vous plaît
c'est pour moi j'avais tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
ces quatre amis aussi merci quand même
le dire j'en ai quand même jetons s'il
vous plaît prenez ce que vous voulez
[Applaudissements]
mais bon voilà
en france en revanche bien moyenne oui
bah oui vous attendez quoi et c'est vrai
c'est vrai ces énoncés sont en revanche
bien là je vais être un petit peu
ric-rac sur nos deux l'eau de boisson
vous n'avez rien dit gabriel vous êtes
êtes très apprécié chez chez les jaunes
est ce que vous êtes déjà abonné très
chaude un exemple c'est vrai pour la
jeunesse il dit c'est une telle réussite
cette phase 1 est ce que c'est important
pour vous d'aller au contact des jeunes
joie vous faites beaucoup de choses avec
les influenceurs
on a fait n'est en effet des missions
semblent aussi chez vous venez vous êtes
touche pas à mon poste aussi c'est le
taux que comme eto'o que sur les genoux
c'est important pour nous aussi de
donner l'exemple
moi je prétends pas représentés tous les
jeunes et toute la jeunesse
d'abord parce que je pense qu'à pas une
jeunesse il ya des jeunes qui ont des
parcours différents qui ont des envies
différentes
par contre je suis conscient du fait que
quand j'ai été nommé l'un des plus
jeunes ministres toute l'histoire la
5ème république c'est ce qu'on m'a
appris quand le jour où j'ai été nommé
et du coup ça me donne une
responsabilité à chaque fois dans toutes
les réunions je suis toutes les
décisions auxquelles je participe et
d'essayer de
en tiennent compte de la jeunesse dans
ce conte dans les décisions qu'on prend
et j'essaye effectivement que dialoguer
avec les jeunes je le fais dans mon
compte instagram
il perd régulièrement je le fais en me
déplaçant sur le terrain je pense que je
suis aussi là pour ça
j'espère que les restaurants vont rester
au reer l'otan c'est reparti aucun
moment ce sera pas que les terrasses et
que ce sera aussi l'intérieur des
restaurants